on this episode we try to keep old Minds
happy we talk about selfies and I don't
remember enjoy the show
you ask questions and I answer them this
is the askgaryvee shut up
hey everybody it's gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 53 of the askgaryvee
show before I get into this episode as
you can tell the setting has changed a
little bit
episode 38 we told you we would get to
floor 15 and we have and before I get
into the questions I have one other
thing to say just a couple episodes ago
I talked about how dear ock was one of
the worst basketball players I had ever
seen with my own two eyes however last
night at the vaynermedia holiday party
we teamed up in cornhole and completely
dominated is NDK around anywhere because
he's devastated of what happened last
night
d-roc when I teamed up with him because
of the lack of hand-eye coordination I
saw on the basketball court I expected
me to completely have to put his body on
my back and carry us to victory however
the man absolutely dominated alongside
with me and we give me go for know who
or no let's get into the shell
Eddy asks what three values do you hold
highest in light Eddy it's a great
question you know I don't know if I have
three values that I hold I just start
rattling off things that I really
appreciate you know I think I think the
first you know thing and I don't know if
this is in any order but I'm a humongous
fan of patience lack of patience has
caused so many people from not achieving
the upside that they deserve and that
kills me you know the value of this word
is bond
I think really matters I think you know
having somebody in your life that you
just know that you can trust because
when they say they're gonna do something
they do it and then in a weird way
contradicting that but not really I'm a
huge fan of somebody who's nimble and
empathetic because when you really think
about it I for example am Telling You
that I love
word is bond but then when somebody
actually does that and doesn't deliver
on it in a weird way I'm ok with it I
don't know and I'm very attracted to
that own characteristic within myself
because I think I understand that even
though Yuri
wanted to you know something happened
that made you not and I want to dig into
why and so I think nimbleness or empathy
is very very very important I think
people that are grateful are extremely
attractive you know nothing's more ugly
to me than than somebody who's spoiled
and I think you know at some level
hypocrisy is the thing I hate the most
in the world so the opposite of that
which is maybe that or I don't know but
those are things that come to mind Chris
asks has a selfie replaced the autograph
and how will it go down at Wine Library
on Saturday Chris the selfie has
replaced the autograph straight up
how will go on Saturday and you're
referencing the Wine Library from 11:00
a.m. to 6:00 p.m. appearance that so
many of you in the vaynernation are not
coming - I read the comments yesterday
you know I don't understand how a man
can't convince his girlfriend to take a
drive from West Virginia you know if you
need to make me call her I will email me
her phone number I'll convince her on
the phone in two minutes and I'm not
even her boyfriend so anyway what's
going to go down is this I think a lot
of people going to come both in the
business in the wine world a lot of
there will be old-time friends that grew
up watching wine RBT maybe even people I
knew when I was a kid growing up in the
store so that will be fun but I expect
to take a whole lot of these absolutely
and more interestingly one of the really
interesting phenomenons that I'm seeing
in trends is how many kids are actually
printing out selfies with famous people
and then posting them in their lockers I
think is really interesting and so for
sure that is now the social you know
autographs are social currency they
represent you can go in your seat go
ahead you go you can go in your seat
okay uh it's your seat
the autograph showed the autograph
showed kind of like that social you know
equity that like hey I met India right
and so now the selfie is even more
powerful more scalable
it is 100% replace the autograph
Jimmy asks what's your favorite city in
the world to drink wine in Jimmy my
favorite city in the world drink wine is
in is the city that has my friends and
family in it at that moment that I'm
sharing that wine with there is no like
you know atmosphere that dictates my
happiness of drinking wine there's no
pretty French Riviera or the gorgeous
mountains I don't give a crap about that
stuff what I care is who am i drinking
it with so I could be in Newark Big Ups
to Newark not dissing if it's with
somebody I love and we're enjoying wine
then that's what is the driving force
and so then it would be Newark the hotel
lobby in Austin South by 2007 is one of
my favorite times of all time of having
wine the parking lot of a Jets game you
know it you know inside the caves of
wineries in Tuscany like this it's
happened in a lot of places but it's
never been the setting I don't care
about that stuff it's been the people
I'm sharing it with Bill asks I'm in
sales for third-generation residential
construction getting my at-bat how do I
increase business but keep old minds
happy bill it's a great question and and
I've got to set this up I may not be the
right person to answer this because my
answer comes with straight venom so get
ready
I truly believe the way that you get old
Minds to accept consume your new ways is
to be extremely rogue and aggressive and
massively disrespectful to them
I get it but old mines are tough to move
if you're going to play within the lines
that they draw you're not going to be
able to do what you want at some level I
had empathy and respect for my dad and
truth is he gave me plenty of room so I
didn't even really live this but I limit
now with vaynermedia where I'm trying to
move old mines where they're b2b and
they're not my dad and they don't know
my brilliance sometimes upfront and
they're not quite sure and it's hard for
me to move it and one of the ways to
move it is to be out-and-out
disrespectful I'm telling you right now
I get it and you don't want your
grandpappy firing you and I understand
all those dynamics but the truth is if
you want to move mountains it's not
going to be by like you can't get it
done like that my man and so to make
change to move things in the right
direction you've got to come with
Thunder it's just the way it is and so
you've got to be a little disrespectful
you've got to tell them they're old and
and this is the big one if you've got
forbid get your chance to do it
you better execute because if you don't
then you're just a kid then you're just
naive then you're just yeah and it's
International Mountain shot show show he
deserves it show it he was paying
attention to the show he was paying
attention to the show that's
unbelievable
he's crowd source stuff I say yeah you
know what these guys are a hell a lot
more fruitful than I closed off I like
these guys more like you guys I think
now to it Michael asks I hope you had a
great time at last night's holiday bash
what's your favorite holiday tradition
Michael hands-down my favorite holiday
tradition is Thanksgiving just going to
my parents house in Hunterdon County
it's just something I don't know I just
love it
obviously we talked about it a couple
episodes ago but it's really just you
know I think you get the theme it's
happened twice here I'm a people person
I'm a family guy that's the one that's
almost like the the non-debatable my dad
screwed up birthdays a couple years ago
by taking my mom to Italy on the
birthday and breaking up the family
dynamics and now I always razz him for
that because I'm a really dear friend
get married during my mom's birthday and
we went away and so now it's broken up a
little bit birthdays used to be pretty
sacred family shifted a little bit on
that one but Thanksgiving is like we've
got to be together we've got to be at
Mom's
it means a lot to me get to see
everybody I love so much and you know
the football games and that me and AJ
doing something crazy like we bought
expensive basketball cards this year you
know just it's always a lot of fun my
sister's kids blah blah blah blah so
Thanksgiving getting together nothing
too crazy nothing too you know wild but
that's the scoop that indeed all right
question of the day give me a little
feedback on your new settings
vaynernation what do you think about
this how do you like it do you enjoy it
you keep asking questions I'll keep
answering them
vaynernation I need you to start
tweeting questions I think we've done a
bad job by reminding you how to show
works which is you've got to ask me a
question use the hashtag askgaryvee and
then you get on the show
dig deep vaynernation dig deep Gary I
have a question for you do you think the
reason why the Jets are so bad this year
is because you made a deal with the
devil don't forget to subscribe to my
youtube channel